DeSantis holds a 14-point lead over
Trump and hypothetical matchup Paul
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis leads
former president Donald Trump off by 14
points on hypothetical 2024 GOP Primary
matchup according to new poll The Wall
Street Journal survey released on
Wednesday found that DeSantis leads
amongst likely Republicans voters 42-52
to 38 the census is also has had an
advantage in his approval rating with 84
percent of Republicans surveyed having a
favor of the U of M by comparison 71
percent said they have a favorable
favorable review of trump view of trump
uh Trump still led the census by 16
points 54 to 38 among respondents who
identify as conservative while descent
has led by 30 points 59-29 among those
who identifies as somewhat conservative
So Adam when you see this what do you
think about these numbers here yeah I
completely believe them uh this is uh
something that we've been talking about
for months I I think that Trump is the
past I think Ron DeSantis is the future
why are we relitigating the past with
Donald Trump I'm using the word
relitigating intentionally because that
guy is buried in dozens of lawsuits
still and just wait until where these
lawsuits end up during his re-election
bid I think there's such a yearning in
this country and by the way this isn't
just a trump thing I think there's a
yearning this country to do away with
Trump and do away with Biden and get
something new in there my biggest fear
is that Trump runs and Biden doesn't run
and we have a Gavin Newsom face off with
Trump and I think Gavin Newsom will beat
Trump and that's okay the biggest odds
Adam I mean you got to take that bet as
soon as possible so just follow the
numbers on Vegas here I think there's
such a yearning what's what there's an
article we just talked about about mask
fatigue yeah over the past I think
there's something uh along the lines of
a trump fatigue and you're starting to
see the cracks in the Trump uh campaign
where like people like uh what's her
what's her name and um
people like her that were just so
completely on board with Trump have
already jumped ships to be fair this
this poll was only 267 people yeah guys
you guys a question do you think there's
validity in it though forget about the
poll do you think there's validity that
and what I'm saying is that there's a
yearning for something I trust wsj the
most out of all the current Publications
current they could change tomorrow I'm
just saying currently Wall Street
Journal WSU is at the top what are they
saying this is wsja uh uh a poll this is
a 14-point lead over a trump this is a
Wall Street Journal
survey is from Wall Street Journal go to
the top Rob
there's a 14-point lead over Trump and
hypothetical yeah I just I listen
Biden's 80 years old by the time Trump
runs again he's gonna be 78 years old
like we want someone new we want someone
fresh we want something he's making a
major announcement tomorrow
here's my question to you guys it's not
a major announcement is he gonna make by
the way great news I'm gonna actually
run again yeah no now I'm dead serious
no but here's my question to you guys
and Tom I want to know what all you guys
think you if you're Ron desantis's
campaign manager how do you get those
die-hard Mega people to get away like
don't get me wrong not be offensive
don't play the whole left oh my God
collusion all that [ __ ] because
obviously they're Republicans too how do
you slowly take that that trump-loving
Maga Pat without being too aggressive to
tell them like Hey listen the the God's
Gonna Change we saw the same mentality
of the Trump but how do you how do you
get those people to come to you like how
you get those people to shift so
one word I don't think this one I don't
think this poll is a surprise eyes I
think we all know that inside the
Republican Party there's not a civil war
now but there's two camps there's a
moderate a moderate conservative cap and
then there's there's Maga and you are
not the maggot people are offended
deeply offended and they're deeply loyal
so until Trump is not on the ballot they
are with him and that is the issue and
that is what everyone is tiptoeing
around as they prepare for the
presidential election everybody's
tiptoeing around nobody wants to nobody
wants to push Trump because that voting
block there is offended and they are
entrenched and they they feel that
they've been ripped off they have been
and so about it yep and so DeSantis
isn't going to do anything to win them
over
by by vigorously campaigning against
Trump it's just going to be you're going
to have the two camps we sought the
Democrat primary you had two groups of
people right group one was very small it
was basically Bernie and
Elizabeth with a little bit of Amy
Klobuchar because she was a more gentle
um Aunt Amy looking person but her hard
socialist views lined up very much with
Elizabeth Warren she just presented them
softer so you had them and then you had
everybody else right and that was the
problem that the Democrats had on stage
it all had to shake out because you
could hold 10 elections out of ten have
everybody present their things and
you're still going to have the same
result until the about until the people
are off the ballot and then the other
folks go oh well well I'm with you yeah
so sometimes here's my question to you
though so let's say because it's going
to look like the santis and Trump are
going to go They're Gonna debate
whatever the scientists hadn't said that
no what I'm saying is let's say they
they go against each other DeSantis wins
right what happens to those die-hard
Mega voters yeah they're voting for
Rhonda Santos I'm not voting for the
Democrat no no that's your answer
do they not vote
no for Ron DeSantis here's the answer
there's one word that you ask what's the
thing yeah the one word is win yeah
here's the problem with Trump he won in
2016. and he gave the speech about
you're gonna win so much you're gonna
get sick of winning
what has Trump won since 2016. they lost
the 2018 midterms he lost the 2020
election there was supposed to be a red
wave in 2022 they lost like they didn't
win the they won they won they lost the
Senate uh they barely won the house that
this whole concept of winning Well Ron
DeSantis wins yeah he wins by landslides
I agree uh and he's winning in places
actually want to win gold the winner the
guy that's winning yeah not the guy who
says he's gonna win now I'm just gonna
be a little Fair here don't count Trump
out I get it he's been there he's done
that I just think there's a yearning in
this country for something new something
fresh something different so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetaining
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three than when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hats
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]